while the weather has been so
comfortable the last few days but
all good things come to an end brian
denise triple digits on the horizon for
us a really good reminder to keep an eye
for heat
dangers christian costar is joining us
live in studio he's got some tips for
medical experts to avoid
a trip to the er that's right brian and
denise well it may seem like common
sense but if you're a local or just
visiting
you might want to pay close attention
basic rule rule number one
is to stay hydrated many people tend to
forget that that's what the team at the
american medical response recommended
they stress the importance of drinking
plenty of water applying sunscreen and
wearing clothing that protects your arms
and legs as well as your face
now the dangerous heat can cause a
sunburn within minutes
some signs to watch out for dizziness
vomiting or
confusion they say the summertime is
their busiest time of the year with a
28 increase in heat related emergency
calls
but the heat can also lead to other
dangers that many people
tend to ignore people want to get into
the pool they want to
you know cool off whatever they need to
do so we're going to also stress when it
comes to water
and make sure you're aware of what's
going on in the water especially with
our little ones
they're so excited to get into the pool
so we really do stress
um safety devices and if you do have a
pool at home
make sure those gates are locked with
pools always busy during the summer
leslie shaffer with the
amr recommends taking a swim class they
never hurt it could
really be a life or death decision in
the future and of course always call
9-1-1
in case of an emergency also as coveted
restrictions roll back and more people
head outside
it's a good reminder that alcohol does
not count for hydrating yourself
amr recommends a cup of water along with
that drink that you get at the bar
christian concert is 8 news now kristin
thank you so we asked on twitter
if you're local does the heat bother you
or by now are you just used to it
here are the numbers 31 percent said
yeah i'm bothered by this heat
69 saying they've gotten used to it